we continue this half-hour with a life
and death story of three young
adventurers they were killed earlier
this week when they fell from the third
highest waterfall in British Columbia in
Canada the social media personalities
were known for posting stunning videos
and photos of daring feats and travel
Kenneth Craig has more Kamath good
morning well good morning to you Anthony
these thrill-seekers had a passion for
travel and fans from all over the world
followed their every move they
encouraged their followers to get out of
their comfort zones but this week their
latest escapade ended in tragedy
their adventures took them around the
globe
not only entertaining their fans with
videos of their daring stunts
but also inspiring them follow your
bliss stop looking for reasons why you
can't and look for reasons why you can
the bloggers were part of the travel
collective high on life their YouTube
videos urged viewers to get out and
explore the world more than a million
fans followed them on Instagram and they
push the limits until the very end when
Ryker gamble Alexei Lai AK and his
girlfriend Megan scraper died after
accidentally plunging nearly 100 feet
over a Canadian waterfall according to
officials the three were swimming on
Tuesday in one of the pools at the top
of Shannon Falls and walking along a
ledge before they fell scraper
reportedly slipped first and the two men
were also swept away trying to save her
the terrain complicated the recovery of
the bodies
there has been a sharp increase in
emergency calls since a nearby gondola
opened says john wilcox of Squamish
search-and-rescue this beautiful area
but along with that comes some pretty
severe terrain and unless people are
educated equipped trained to to access
some of these areas it has potential for
great risk
last year gamble lie AK and another
member of high on life were banned from
US federal land after pleading guilty to
violations at four national parks the
three who were killed made a living on
social media traveling the world scraper
said it was a life most people can only
dream of it's intense and you don't know
what you're doing there's ups and downs
but at the end of the day there's just
nothing like doing your own thing they
were three of the warmest kindest most
driven and outgoing people that you
could ever meet
in an emotional post remaining members
of the group remembered their friends
they lived every single day to its
fullest they stood for positivity
courage and living the best life that
you can and they shared and taught their
values to millions of people worldwide
in that video those friends went on to
encourage fans to share their own
stories about how high on life inspired
them tributes have been pouring in on
social media Anthony Kenneth Craig
thanks Kenneth